et notre invité ce matin c'est karima
delli bonjour mr joue beaucoup d'être
avec nous des recettes européen europe
ecologie les verts
vous présidez au parlement européen la
commission transport et tourisme
on va parler bien sûr de tous ces sujets
on est ensemble pendant 20 min pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représente lui
faire éric richard bonjour c'est une
première pour vous ici on est ravi de
vous recevoir de la nouvelle république
du centre-ouest merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous on commence bien sûr karima
delli par la situation sanitaire 1 600
milles vaccination traite 600000 un peu
plus de 580 m ils exactement
en france à ce jour la lenteur du
gouvernement elle a été beaucoup
critiqué au début de la campagne de
vaccination est ce que finalement les
critiques ont été trop rapide est ce que
compte tenu du nombre restreint de doses
dont on dispose en provenance de l'union
européenne la stratégie de la france n'a
pas été la bonne mais elle est pas la
bonne parce que dès le début de la crise
sanitaire c'est la politique du couac
on l'a vu sur la question des masques on
nous a dit au départ bas c'était ça ne
servait à rien ensuite on a eu la même
polémique sur la question des tests et
au fait à chaque fois qu'ils arrivent
quelque chose au lieu de tirer les
conclusions et les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé
eh ben on continue et là dans la
politique je dire sur le plan de la
vaccination nationale là aussi il ya un
manque terrible et un défaut
d'anticipation qui est quand même vu et
on a vu qu'on était quand même le 26e
voire 25 27 à enclencher la dynamique
mais pourquoi on en est là la véritable
question elle est là en est là parce que
je crois que tout le monde veut avoir
son mot à dire dans les politiques de
crise sanitaire
par exemple on a le ministre des
transports qui dit vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir
26 millions notamment de vacciner à la
fin de l'année deux jours après il est
repris par le porte parole qui dit bah
non c'est pas fun 6 millions c'est
finalement 15 millions vous voyez de qui
est un truc déjà qui va pas en plus il
n'y a pas de méthode et on va pas se
dire les allers retours de stratégie les
changements de stratégie qui met
en danger notamment des professions je
pense monde de la culture
je monte je pense au monde de
l'hôtellerie des restaurants c'est tout
le temps du la stratégie du stop and go
voyait ce qui crée des crispations alors
moi je le dis de manière très simple
aujourd'hui la situation ne va pas elle
va pas parce que vous voyez bien qu'on a
des plateformes surchargées des
rendez-vous qui s'étale jusqu'au mois de
mai sur les différents territoires
on voit qu'aujourd'hui des élus locaux
qui sont en stress permanent
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un
moment il faut changer la méthode la
méthode la première chose à faire
début faut pas attendre qu à des couacs
pourrir on va changer encore de méthode
ça c'est la première chose d'eux mais la
pharmacie emblème c'est qu'on manque de
doses et c'est l'union européenne qui a
fait ce qui a eu un problème dans la
stratégie vaccinale de l'union rentrée
alors il faut faire attention aux
heureusement qu'il y a eu le rop la
france pour pouvoir négocier l'ensemble
de ces doses à cette quantité là à cette
rapidité à n'aurais pas pu le faire tout
seul
donc heureusement qu'à l'europe
maintenant l'europe et moi je lui dis un
les écologie / les premiers on va avoir
on demande des comptes aussi à la
commission européenne ce et quel type de
contrat a été fait notamment avec ces
laboratoires pharmaceutiques elle
quelles ont été les prix par exemple
vous voyez donc derrière il ya aussi des
problèmes qui vont se poser après mais
nous les posons maintenant en termes de
transparence
mais ce n'est pas à cause de l'europe
faut faire attention à ça l'europe
heureusement a été là pour faire
commander sur les 27 pour mieux répartir
selon le nombre d'habitants et c'est
maintenant pressé les stratégies de
chaque état la stratégie française n'a
pas été la bonne on passe du couac
aujourd'hui au fiasco parce qu on ne
regardait en dix ans qu'est ce que c'est
que ce délire et ensuite il faut
absolument écouter travailler avec des
élus locaux qui sont de bonne foi qui
sont là pour défendre l'intérêt général
a pas de la politique politicienne mais
en tout cas je pense que la méthode n'a
pas été la bonne
et justement dans cette crise il ya eu
bien sûr l'attitude de l'allemagne alors
qu'à pas vraiment joué collectif si l'on
peut dire
c'est une péripétie pour l'union ou bien
est ce que c'est le signe d'un mal un
peu plus profond alors il faut faire
attention
il faut rappeler aux téléspectateurs que
la santé ce n'est pas une compétence de
l'union européenne moi j'aspire à ce que
la crise sanitaire puisse être un
tremplin pour que demain on est une
vraie politique de santé en europe ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que lorsque madame van der
heijden prend la décision avec des chefs
d'états de commandé ces vaccins pour les
il faut savoir que un moment là les des
des contrats directement investisseurs
sauf qu est ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'un peu l'europe a sifflé la fin de la
récré c'est pour ça que madame von der
leyen a rappelé à recommander des
vaccins donc vous voyez la stratégie
isolé ça ne marche pas tellement
pourquoi parce que derrière on sait
aussi c'est la question de la
tarification
maintenant vous posez une vraie question
c'est à dire que l'europe doit se doter
aussi parce qu'on voit que vous le dit
un petit peu quand vous dites mais
attendez il manque de deux vaccins à
deux doses
il faut absolument en termes
d'approvisionnement créer une politique
notamment sur la production de ces
vaccins et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
même les belges ont des problèmes
logistiques et donc même nous en france
vous savez le président de la république
il a dit une chose extraordinaire après
la crise il a dit après la crise il
faudra en repenser le monde dehors et
tous ont relocalisé mais nous avons
aussi nous vous savez en avait on à
l'institut pasteur
on a laboratoires pharmaceutiques qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on n'a rien fait on n'a
pas anticipé et donc l'europe va devoir
dans les prochains mois voire dans les
prochaines années à avoir une vraie
stratégie sanitaire européenne on en est
loin pour l'instant moi je trouve qu'on
en ait un petit peu loin de ce qu'on
devrait faire maintenant elle a pris des
initiatives l'europe qui était pas
forcément dans ses compétences
et pourtant elle l'a fait sur notamment
ce risque sanitaire
même si on peut regretter qu'au
démarrage c'était un petit peu difficile
parce que souvenez vous les premiers ont
été les italiens on a attendu les cris
d' alerte des italiens pour pouvoir
d'abord les aider voyez donc là aussi il
ya des choses qui se sont faites et on
peut reconnaître - ce rôle là l'europe
on va parler des frontières et quand
c'est un sujet qui met sur la table en
au sein de l'union européenne oui tout à
fait ces deux lits nous nous nous avons
effectivement la réunion des chefs
d'état demain alors faut-il à vos yeux
je dirais durcir les contrôles aux
frontières
on sait on parle encore une fois de
l'allemagne qui n'exclut pas de rétablir
ces ces contrôles est-ce que d'une
manière générale
karima delli vous diriez que la france a
une attitude trop laxistes je dirais pas
ça parce qu'en fait c'est toujours
facile de de dire la france aurait dû et
savent que on est le pays européen qui a
le plus de frontière avec l'espagne avec
l'italie avec l'allemagne les les
suisses les belges et c'est ce qui fait
que nous sommes un vrai pays
transfrontaliers
nous avons cinq cent mille travailleurs
donc tous ceux qui disent on va fermer
les frontières ça c'est des bêtises ça
c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que nous on a un
patchwork sur la question des contrôles
par exemple si je vais notamment en
belgique
je devrai montré un test pcr négatif où
ce sera sept jours sept jours notamment
d'isolement quand je vais en allemagne
on me demande un test pcr négatif de -2
72 heures quand je vais en italie
c'est un test pcr ou où une quarantaine
qui sera imposée et là ça va pas bien
parce que c'est chaque état qui décide
donc je dis ce que moi je demande au
chef d'état c'est d'avoir un
renforcement des contrôles
si on fait des tests pcr sont dix et
sept jours de quarantaine pour tout le
monde
sept jours louis de quarantaine pour
tout le monde ou soit on fait les mêmes
mesures même à l'international
parce que là ça devient important
puisque le gouvernement français a
décidé il y a deux jours de dire que
tous les ressortissants hors union
européenne devait à la sortie de l'avion
présenté un test pcr négatif ou
ou alors tout de suite rentré dans
l'isolément mais là il ya un problème
aussi pourquoi parce que si vous
demandez à des gens d'avoir un test et
qu'ils n'ont pas donc vous le faites
notamment à l'aéroport
si vous êtes positif et bien il faut des
structures pour isoler les gens les
hôtels etc
vous voyez est donc ça ça s'organise et
donc moi j'aspire à ce que le conseil
européen qui se tiendra jeudi renforce
les mesures de contrôle est aussi fasse
attention à tous les travailleurs
transfrontaliers qui eux ne peuvent être
pas et perturber duran duran justement
cette période là parce qu'ils ont besoin
de travailler dernière question là
dessus c'est la question du passeport
vaccinale à un les mises sur la table
notamment par le premier ministre grec
qui lui demandant un certificat commun
reconnu par tous les pays de l'union
européenne pour pouvoir voyager sans
contraintes aussi en europe et un
orphelin van der heyden d'ailleurs a dit
qu'elle n'était pas contre vous quelle
est votre position là dessus
pour l'instant la question du passeport
vaccinale ne se pose pas puisque tout le
monde n'est pas vaccinée c'est à dire
que ceux qui seraient vaccinés aurait un
passeport et les autres donc on crée
plus de droits à ceux qui seraient
vaccinés au dock sacré vraiment 1 1
on va avoir un climat de double vitesse
pour eux certaines personnes et pas
d'auto que la position du gouvernement
français d'aujourd'hui n'a pas lieu
d'être
maintenant la véritable question et je
tiens à le relever pourquoi les grecs le
demandent
parce que vivent de l'économie du
tourisme et donc ce passeport là pour
être un volet un outil important pour
relancer la machine mais en tout cas
nous ne pourrons pas le faire juste à
titre d'un pays
voilà on va parler de l'actualité en
france et c'est aujourd'hui la
présentation en conseil des ministres de
ce projet de loi qui permet d'inscrire
dans l'article 1 de la constitution la
protection de l'environnement la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
voulue par emmanuel macron qui veut
passer par référendum sauf qu'il faut
qu'il soit voté dans les mêmes termes
par l'assemblée et le sénat vous le
savez très bien et le sénat il n'est pas
favorable gérard larcher il dit que
l'environnement ne doit pas être au
dessus des autres libertés fondamentales
et donc pas figurer dans l'article 1 de
la constitution est ce que c'est un
argument vous entendez vous comprenez
écoutez cet article un ils étaient
prônée depuis des années par les
écologistes pour nous c'est pas nouveau
mais serait faire cette inscription
notamment de la constitution ça ne doit
pas être l'arbre notamment qui cache la
forêt des renoncements
pourquoi parce que qu'est ce que vient
faire cette proposition aujourd'hui elle
vient parce qu'il ya eu la convention
citoyenne où pendant neuf mois des
citoyens ont proposé des choses très
concrètes
vous voyez et ont dit on va vous allez
on va peut balayer ça on va faire un
petit coup de com petites manoeuvres
politiciennes et ensuite je vais sortir
gagnant pourquoi je vais sortir gagnant
parce que si le sénat refuse
eh ben on aura un président de la
république qui va dire j'ai essayé et si
le sénat axel va dire un j'ai réussi mon
coup
voyez mais là c'est pas le bon je vais
dire c'est pas de la bonne vision ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui et je tiens
à rappeler parce que quand on anticipe
dans un gouvernement
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas anticipé que
cette crise sanitaire est due notamment
à une perte de biodiversité à des
écosystèmes qui aujourd'hui vont très
mal donc tout le monde devrait être au
coeur de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et la crise
climatique d'eau qu'il faut prendre au
sérieux notamment pas sur un bout de
papier
même si c'est la constitution mais dans
les actes réellement et donc qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
allons-y isolons les bâtiments
interdisant les les
les véhicules les plus polluants
arrêtons la publicité revenons sur les
accords de libre échange comme avec le 7
1 vous voyez toute la panoplie de
mesures qui sont pas non plus très
contraignant de la convention cités
qu'est ce qu'on attend eh bien là c'est
un manque de courage politique et je
redis de manière très sérieuse parce que
nous avons fêté les cinq ans des accords
de paris nous étions un petit peu il ya
cinq ans vous savez les teneurs du
marteau là avec monsieur fabius qui
disait vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir nous allons
être là bang à aujourd'hui nous sommes
un peu les cancres de la classe
européenne sur cette question climatique
parce que nous allons pas assez en avant
justement au sein de ce gouvernement
barbara pompili que vous connaissez bien
et donc et donc ministre et donc aux
affaires moi j'ai envie de vous demander
à vos yeux est ce qu'elle est toujours
écologistes et d'une manière plus
générale est ce qu'elle est une bonne
ministre
alors moi je connais très bien barbara
pompili c'est une amie et je ne vais pas
tirer à boulet rouge sur barbara le
problème de fond c'est que la politique
écologique de ce pays ne se décide pas
au ministère de l'écologie il se décide
à l'elysée est donc le problème elle
approche la vraie problématique c'est
pas barbara pompili c'est comment un
président de la république est de ma
génération c'est fou ne comprend pas eu
l'opportunité incroyable de la
transition écologique
c'est là où c'est extraordinaire on doit
montrer à quel point la transition
écologique c'est bon pot climat mais
c'est aussi bon pour l'emploi
lorsqu'on dit que demain on doit être
dans un pays de plein de santé allons-y
traitons la crise sanitaire avec quand
même avec des pâtes des oeillères juste
sur le volet sanitaire
ouvrons en montrant que les causes
viennent du dérèglement climatique et de
la perte de la biodiversité juste que
par la pompe il y est elle est là mais
n'a aucun moyen d'action en fait je
mangeais lui dit quand elle est rentrée
au gouvernement je lui ai souhaité bonne
chance mais on voit bien que la première
chose qui est quand même fou c'est que
le en même temps ça marche pas et la
première chose à dire qu'on défend la
planète les césar et en même temps on
réintroduit les néonicotinoïdes voyez ça
marche pas on défend la planète et
cetera on sort pas du glyphosate je vais
pas faire toutes les listes parce que je
pourrais rester deux heures mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que ces êtres écologie
c'est sortir ses contradictions et ses
dettes cohérent et on voit bien que là
ya pas de cohérence
eric on termine avec vous sur les
régionales oui sur les élections
régionales en effet vous êtes vous même
une tête de liste alors j'irai est ce
que vous estimez tout d'abord que la
région est une bonne échelle pour faire
de l'écologie tout simplement
absolument je pense que les régions
aujourd'hui ont des sondes élevé
d'actions pour rentrer de plein fouet et
vite dans la transition écologique
vous savez moi je suis la présidente de
la commission transports au sein du
parlement européen
la compétence transport c'est le plus
gros budget c'est au minimum ou 40% sur
ces leviers là nous pouvons faire plein
de choses relancer le fret ferroviaire
qu'est ce qu'on attend
on peut relancer des lignes qu'on a
fermé on peut aménager plus de vélos
dans les trains on peut faire en sorte
que cette mobilité demain soit plus
accessible plus moins polluantes
et puis surtout faire en sorte que ça
travaille sur une des grandes
problématiques française puisqu'on vient
d'être encore condamné puisque on ne met
pas en oeuvre la directive qualité de
l'air
donc les régions c'est un véritable
levier d'action pour mettre en place la
transition écologique et la justice
sociale parce que nous avons aussi des
compétences pour pouvoir remédier à
toutes là l'ensemble des problématiques
sociales quand je vois la hausse de la
précarité et notamment sur la jeunesse
la jeunesse qui a été la grande oubliée
et ça ça va être un des grands enjeux de
ces élections
alors vous êtes parti très tôt dans
cette campagne on se souvient que ya
déjà plusieurs mois vous aviez désigner
des binômes chef de file puis vous avez
désigné les têtes de liste compte tenu
des incertitudes qui pèsent encore à ce
jour sur le calendrier et l'échéance
électorale elle-même est ce que vous
n'êtes pas parti un petit peu tôt je ne
crois pas je pense que vous demandez à
n'importe qui dans la rue à quoi sert à
conseil régional je pense que les gens
savent pas donc voilà donc on part tôt
parce qu'on veut montrer à quel point
faire de la pédagogie sur wii les les
conseils régionaux demain sont des
véritables lieux vides action mais ce
sont aussi des maisons des citoyens dont
qui comprennent avec nous l'organisation
de ces instances à c'est la première et
la deuxième chose je le dis de manière
très claire nous pour nous les écologies
la santé est la priorité
mais convient pas nous convient pas nous
faire de la manoeuvre politique
politicienne
quand j'apprends qui hier jean louis
debré dit concrètement et l'accuse un
peu l'exécutif d'avoir un peu incités à
reporter les élections régionales
après les présidentielles j'étais là dès
lors de nos deux sur toi là je dis stop
la démocratie ne peut pas être confinée
si on peut pas rendre des transports si
on peut aller travailler on peut aller
voter ça veut dire quoi il faut
s'organiser
puis le bureau de vote on étale les
plages les plages horaires pour pouvoir
réellement avoir le temps de voter
maintenant la véritable question s'est
il faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des idiots parce que ça les
gouvernements pour vous ben moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui comme ils ont vu que les
municipales ça n'a pas marché pour leur
parti politique
il se dit on va faire ça après les
présidentielles puisque quand c'est une
présente elle il ya une dynamique
derrière vous savez au niveau local donc
maintenant je dis faut siffler la fin de
la récré parce que derrière ce sont des
enjeux qui sont majeurs pour nos régions
donc ça sera
[Musique]